hey believe nation its Evan my one word
is believe and I believe in you and I
want to see that thing you've got inside
of you come out and have a big impact on
the world I started that meant to me
serious - hang on people who've done
more than us and hopefully we can learn
from them the way they think their
mindsets their beliefs to help us be the
best version of ourselves so today we're
gonna learn from Kobe Bryant and some of
his best motivation mentor me Kobe and
as always guys as you're watching if you
hear something that really resonates
with you please leave it down the
comments below put quotes around us or
other people can be inspired as well and
when you write it down it's much more
likely to stick with yourself - joy
[Music]
you
I'll seize I was just waiting and
waiting for my opportunity to come I
wanted to prove that I was better than
they thought I was you know I'm going to
prove to myself that I'm better than
they think I was and I was mentally
preparing myself and visualizing the
moment that would come where
I lead to Los Angeles Lakers to a big
day
I've been with you for a long way at the
one moment that stands out out of we've
done I don't know how many don't we've
done no play 800 events the one time was
4 a.m. we went out to practice at 4 a.m.
and that was your idea to do it well
then you know all these Nike people are
like no no no no no let's not let's not
do that and then you're like let's do it
at 4 a.m. so you got security
you got brand marketing a sports
marketing going no no no no no no that's
not good you're like let's do it because
that's your sustenance I mean to me it
just makes complete sense not to us see
we all right what you usually I'm
sleeping at 4 a.m. you're you're working
out well I like about that ok so if if
your job is to try to be the best
basketball player you can be alright to
do that you have to practice you have to
train right
you want to train as much as you can as
often as you can so if you get up at
10:00 in the morning
train at 11/9/12 say 12:00 train at
12:00 train for two hours 12 to 2 you
have to let your body recover so you eat
recover whatever you get back out you
train start training it at 6:00 train
from 6 to 8 right and now you go home
and shower you eat dinner you go to bed
you wake up do it again right those are
two sessions all right now imagine you
wake up at 3 you train at 4 you go 4 to
6 come home breakfast relax so so now
you're back at it again 9 to 11 right
relax and now it's on your back at it
again to the 4 and have you're back at
it again
you know 7 to 9 look how much more
training I have done by simply starting
at 4 right and so now you do that and as
the years go on the separation that you
have with your competitors and your
peers just grows larger and larger and
larger and larger and larger and by year
five or six doesn't matter what kind of
work they're doing a summer they're
never going to catch up because they're
five years behind so it makes sense to
get up and start your day early because
you can get more working is that genetic
or is that something you you engrained
and trained yourself
no it was just you that for me it was
just it was just common sense like I can
okay
I start earlier I can train more hours
and I know the other guys aren't doing
it because I know what their training
schedule is right so I know if I do this
consistently over time is the gaps just
gonna widen and why no why no why no why
and they won't be able to get that back
mm-hmm so it's me it was just common
sense I'm like thinking how can I get an
advantage Oh start earlier yeah let's do
that how do you how do you develop that
or where do you what do you learn that
from well I think it's just no it's just
a matter of what's important to you
mm-hmm
what's important to you for whatever
reason you know I I felt like I didn't
feel good about myself if I wasn't doing
everything I could to be the best
version of myself if I felt like I left
anything on a table it would eat away at
me I wouldn't be able to look myself in
the mirror right so the reason why I can
retire now and be completely comfortable
about it because I know that I've done
everything I could to be the best
basketball player I could be and so
that's where it comes from for me you
can't leave any stone unturned
[Music]
[Applause]
I wish you have the passionate thing
that you're passionate about now you can
look at other people or other entities
or other things or works of art you can
draw things from that to help you be
better at what you do by looking for
those common denominators I don't even
know how do I prepare her how do I
prepare how do I study how do I view the
game how do you build your game and my
response is much like the way he builds
products and you think sequentially oh
yeah you look at this the end result of
what you want to create but in order to
create that there's so many other little
things that go into this massive entity
that or
device it's no different than building
my basketball game you start with where
you want your game to be will we make
your game most unstoppable or hard to
deal with and now you work backwards
from there and you start building in one
piece at a time
one move at a time one counter so
there's a lot of similarities there
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
you were quoted in on CNBC as saying
that you'd rather be remembered for your
role in jump-starting tech companies
than your skills on the core can you
talk to the but what's that about I
think you have to challenge yourself to
evolve and to grow and I think I
couldn't think of a better message for
your athletes in particular because it's
very easy for us a athletes to kind of
lose ourselves and our identity by
connecting who we are to what we do and
I think that's a very dangerous zone to
be in right so it's it's common sense to
me to be able to say okay the next stage
we're going after with the same
intensity the same attention to detail
the same curiosity so of course I'd want
to be better at that than I was in my
previous career there's a pretty high
bar there you have you have enough
energy left for that orange I guess
we're gonna find out right I mean that
best thing you know you go for it and
you do all you can you learn as much as
you can't you continue to try to
continue to improve you continue to
evolve the agency where you are right
you know 20 years from now you can I can
look at a mirror and say I gave it my
best shot and we did the best we could
and see where we end up
[Music]
Paterson Kobe
[Music]
I mean you know the passion came from
the love for the game you know I loved
everything about it like the smell of
the ball you love the smell of the ball
this ball you know the smell of like
brand-new sneakers and like the sound
the ball meets when it hits the ground
sneakers in the gym yeah the ball going
through the net like all those things I
love and so the passion comes from that
because once you have that love you just
want to be a part of this thing all the
time
is there one moment where you can say it
defined your passion for basketball is
there a story or a moment when you said
that wasn't it that was it that was like
when I felt really passionate no I
it doesn't never leave never leaves like
that you know the game was just a part
of me so it never leaves even now that
I'm retired you know everything I've
learned from the game of basketball
carried it over into life you know like
basketballs helped me be a better person
a better friend but how solid well
because there's life lessons that are
within the game like communications like
unselfishness my attention to detail and
empathy and compassion like all those
things are in the game and as an athlete
if we are aware of those things it helps
us become better human human beings
mm-hmm and you can apply that toward
your post post basketball days
retirement into your business world
Mitra ventures sure I mean you can play
you know I was applying that even while
I was playing just in life outside of
the game and even more so now you know
I'm building a business and all these
things you know kind of culture you when
I have all those things are or directly
learn from the game of basketball
[Music]
in the trial
as a student of the game
how important is it to remain a Laker to
keep your your legendary status intact
have a statue in front of the Staples
Center all of the great things that
they've done for some of their all-time
greats and I was up most importance like
I was such a die-hard fan Laker fan
growing up man and just my personality
like it was for me to ask for a trade or
to go play someplace else to try to
chase the championship that's not me man
that's not being that's not what my
career has been about that's not who I
am
and I stay with it the stuff that I've
been through in my life and then to my
career and just taught me anything is
the fact that you'll have good moments
and bad moments have great moments you
have horrible moments you just keep
going through all of them and then
things work themselves out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
once upon a time there was a young
basketball player who had dreams of
becoming one of the greatest basketball
players of all time
hey what 17 years old with the hunger
motivation and a desire to be the best
possible basketball player got to be he
worked day and night every day for years
and years and years and years and years
as time went on twenty years had passed
he felt that he had accomplished all
that he set out to accomplish but would
he come to realize is that the goal that
he set out initially of becoming the
greatest of all time was a very fickle
one when you realize that the most
important thing in life is how your
career moves and touches those around
you and how it carries forward to the
next generation
but he realize that's what makes true
greatness the story would be about
transformation of a kid looking inwardly
to then growing up and understanding the
importance and the power is look it out
it's a great feeling to know that you're
set a goal for yourself
you were able to reach that goal let's
not do that
find the power to turn back time I
wouldn't never use it think about it
because then every moment that you go
through means absolutely nothing because
you can always go back and do it again
so it loses its flavor its loses its its
BB when things are final and you know
moments won't ever come again to be able
to have the power to go back and
experience those things is it's silly to
me
you take that time very at peace with it
and very thankful you know for the for
the 20 years that I've had and ready to
go
[Music]
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed I'd love to know what
did you take from this video what was a
single most important message that you
are going to immediately apply somehow
to your life or to your business leave
it down in the comments below I look
forward to hearing what you have to say
I also want to give a quick shout out to
Megan from the bootstrap boutique
YouTube channel Megan thank you so much
for picking up a copy of my book your
one word and doing that YouTube video
review on it I really really really
appreciate your support and I'm so glad
you enjoyed the read thank you guys so
much for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon the most important
word ever
if you had to think of one word that's
most important to you that sums you
Apple so it would be like a little
beacon pay believe nation if you want to
know what the most important one word is
for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details
[Music]